حيث اصدرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه رساله
لمقاتلي فاجنر قالت فيها انك انه تم
خداعكم في مغامره بريكوجين الاجراميه
والمشاركه في تمرد مسلح وفق تعبير البيان
واضافت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان اعضاء من
مجموعه فاغنر طلب المساعده في تامين
عودتهم الى نقاط انتشارهم الدائم كما قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى على مقاتلي
فاجنر التحلي بالحكمه والتواصل مع ممثلين
واجهزه انفاذ القانون باسرع وقت من جانبها
قالت لجنه مكافحه الارهاب الروسيه انه تم
فرض نظام مكافحه الارهاب في العاصمه
الروسيه ومقاطعه موسكو تحسبا لاعمال
ارهابيه كما قالت اللجنه انه تم فرض نظام
مكافحه الارهاب في مقاطعه فورونيج
المحاذيه لمقاطعه روستوس
اعلن قائد مجموعه ايفاغنر العسكريه
الروسيه
سيطره قواته على المنشات العسكريه في
مقاطعه روستوف مع قلي قياده العمليات
العسكريه بما فيها المطار العسكريه وقد
نشرت مواقع عسكريه روسيه صورا للقاء جمع
بريكوجين بناء وزير الدفاع الروسي يونس
في مدينه رستوف على نهر الدون التي دخلتها
اليوم قوه فاغنر وهدد بريكوجين خلال
اللقاء بالسيطره على كامل رستوب والتوجه
الى موسكو في حال لم يتم تسليمه وزير
الدفاع ورئيسه هيئه الاركان
انضم الينا من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امينه
درغامي اذا امين تطورات متسارعه حديثا عن
اخر المستجدات في هذه القضيه
[تصفيق]
نعم سهام اخر ما صدر هو هذه الرساله من
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى مقاتلي فاجنر
تقول بانهم تعرضوا لخداع في ما سمته
مغامره من قبل
للقيام بتمرد عسكري وقالت انها قدمت
بالفعل المساعده لعدد من القاده العسكريين
وايضا مقاتلين في شركه فاجنر العسكريه من
اجل العوده الى نقاط انتشارهم
الدائم واضافت طبعا في هذه الرساله ان على
مقاتلي شركه فاغنر الاتصال في اسرع وقت
بممثلي وزاره الدفاع وايضا اجهزه انفاذ
القانون من اجل عودتهم الى هناك طبعا هذا
وهذه الرساله صدرت بعد توجه مدير شركه
فاقنار ليفغيني الى مركز قياده العمليات
المشتركه
كما تطلق عليه روسيا بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا وهو مقر قياده المنطقه
الجنوبيه العسكريه في مدينه رستوف واعلن
عن ان قوته تسيطر على كل المنشات العسكريه
في المدينه بما فيها المطارات لكنها لا
تقوم باعاقه سير العمليه العسكريه بما في
ذلك توجه المقاتلات الروسيه الى مهامها
القتاليه طبعا بعد ذلك كان بريجوجن ايضا
قد نشرت مقطعا قال فيه بان طبعا قوته دخلت
الى رستوف وسيطره او توجهت الى مركز
القياده العسكري بناء على تلك التراكمات
التي جرى الحديث عنها من قبل في وقت سابق
والتي اشتدت منذ ان اتهم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه والجيش الروسي باستهداف احد مراكز
انتشار قواته في هجوم صاروخي لجنه مكافحه
الارهاب الوطنيه الروسيه اعلنت بعد ذلك
فرض النظام مكافحه الارهاب في العاصمه
موسكو وفي مقاطعه موسكو وايضا في مقاطعه
فارونج المحاديه
ايضا تشديدات امنيه في اطار هذا القانون
او هذا النظام تتمثل طبعا في اغلاق بعض
الطرق
اقامه حواجز امنيه
ووضع كل الاجهزه الامنيه على اهبه
الاستعداد لما قالت اللجنه انه احتماليه
تعرض
لهجمات ارهابيه الكرملين اعلن من جانبه
على ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ستكون له كلمه متلفزه بعد قليل لكنه حتى
الان سهام لم يحدد موعد الكلمه التي
ينتظرها الجميع في الحقيقه هنا في روسيا
باعتبار
بوتين لم يعلق قط على ما يجري ليس فقط بعد
هذا تصعيد الذي بدا مساء امس بل ومنذ
اشهر عده عندما كان يتهم فيها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بالخذلان بعدم مده بما
يحتاجه من دخائر واسلحه باتهام بعض
الجنرالات والقاده العسكريين بما فيهم
وزير الدفاع الروسي بالخيانه
يعني
التعمد في اعاقه العمليه العسكريه
والتحركات العسكريه
لقوات فاغنر الكثيرون يعاونون في الحقيقه
كما قلت على هذه الكلمه التي
ينتظر بحسب مراقبين ان يتم فيها وضع
الصوره الكامله التي من خلالها ستتعامل
السلطات الروسيه في شكل الكريملين في شكل
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على ما يطلق عليه
الان بمحاوله تمرد عسك
مسلح يقوده قائد مجموعه فاقنار
طبعا الانظار ايضا تتوجه الى ما ستسفر عنه
التحركات العسكريه لفاجنر في مدينه روسطوف
معقل الجيش الروسي في المنطقه العسكريه
الجنوبيه بعد ان كان قد هدد بالسيطره على
مركز قياده المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه في
حال لم يتم احضار رئيس هيئه الاركان
الروسي وايضا وزير الدفاع في ذلك النقاش
المصور الذي دار بين بريجوجن ونائب وزير
الدفاع الروسي الجنرال يونس بيك
طبعا كانت هناك انباء تحدثت عن
تعرض
احدى او كما قال طبعا في ذلك الفيديو
المصور على انه على ان قوته اسقطت ثلاثه
مروحيات عسكريه رو وتحدث عن استهداف حافله
لكنه لم يوضح في الحقيقه
تفاصيل تلك الحافله ماذا جرى بالضبط هل هي
حافله هي حافله تقل عناصر من قوات فاجنر
ام انها حافله مدنيه على الطريق السريع ام
4 الرابط بين روستوف ومدينه
الانباء القادمه من هناك تتحدث عن اغلاق
جزئي لعدد من القطاعات في تلك الطريق
الحيويه وهي الطريقه الرئيسيه سهام
الرابطه بين الشمال روسيا وجنوبها هناك
تكدس للسيارات في منطقه
التي تبعد بنحو 100 كم عن مدينه رستوف
بحسب ما اعلنت السلطات تلك المنطقه بعد
ذلك اعلنت عدد من المقاطعات الروسيه بما
فيها
فارونج مقاطعه موسكو وايضا مقاطعه روستوف
الغاء كل الفعاليات الجماهيريه
لحفظ الامن وذلك طبعا في اطار هذه
الاجراءات المتخذه سواء على مستوى لجنه
مكافحه الارهاب الوطنيه الروسيه او وزاره
الدفاع او حتى الحرس الوطني
وباقي القطاعات العسكريه والامنيه هنا في
روسيا التي وضعت كلها على اهبه الاستعداد
بعد هذا التصعيد الذي نراه الان والذي
يقوده طبعا مؤسس شركه فاناري
[تصفيق]